welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and major spoilers for episode 4 of
peacemaker coming up because this will
be a breakdown of all the fun easter
eggs and things that you miss from what
is hands down the best thing the dcu has
ever put out thanks to james gunn the
masterpiece maker himself and frankly
aeroshem's gift to nerd kind because
this man doesn't miss he'd never miss he
just has never missed so let us go on
ahead and break this thing on down like
vigilante broke down in the passenger
seat my nerd babies because oh my god
there are things to talk about here and
right away the episode starts off with a
super beautiful wide shot of an
underappreciated chauffeur john
economist driving task force x super
secret agent certified undercover
ecstatic truck in a shot that is very
reminiscent to the way that james gunn
opens up guardians of the galaxy vol 2
with ego and meredith driving down a
long and sunny road and much like
meredith those people have no idea that
they're riding with a killer alien
because none of those people seem to
know about mern's secret straw but also
the bottom of the sign for the x-static
electrical truck reads our staff are
plugged in to light up your day which i
think could be a really fun nod to how
task force x plugs bombs into their
criminal staffs brains to light up their
days if they misbehave if you know what
i mean but moving on something that i'm
noticing about the amazingly
choreographed and executed intro to
peacemaker i'm getting the feeling that
it's being implied here that all the
cast members have been possessed by
butterflies like they all seem to be
dancing as part of one big alien shared
hide mind especially with the way that
harcourted mirn into the sequence with
their arms out like puppets but hey then
again not all that off considering that
all the agents of task force x are just
as disposable to waller as human bodies
are to all of these butterflies and a
little later peacemaker continues the
trend of making the most obscure and
ridiculous characters from dc comics
past canon in the dc eu with peacemakers
shoutout to madder eaterlad the dc hero
with the power too you guessed it eat
andy and all matter at will and without
getting nausea heartburn indigestion
upset stomach or diarrhea no wonder he's
from the planet bismol that's not a joke
like there is actually a
pepto-bismol-ass krypton in the dc
universe where everybody on that planet
evolved to be able to eat anything in
the universe because a plague made all
of their food inedible and a little
later on in the episode we can see our
favorite little superhero bunny ultra
bunny on vigilante's dash with a message
that reads obstacles are opportunities
which put a huge smile on my face
because i knew that ultra bunny and this
quote are both original creations of
james gunn because obstacles are
opportunities is a personal motto of
james gunn as he revealed on twitter did
you just hear that sound it's the cry
and the wind that only the chosen one
can hear and i think the chosen one is
you why didn't you tell me what the heck
call of anti is a brand new type of rpg
game it mixes the classic match 3 puzzle
gameplay and a cool fantasy theme with
all the magic and dragons that you love
you can download it for free from the
link in the video's description or by
scanning the qr code on the screen
collect epic heroes find legendary
dragons and do battle against your
enemies in this super visually engaging
game i've been playing this game and i
love all the fantasy elements they
really add a whole new element to the
kinds of puzzle games we've all played
every big combo is a sword attack or a
magical spell which is super dope and
they have multiple battle modes and
events going on all the time that give
you free in-game items and the best
price of all is free download call of
auntia today from the link in this
video's description or from scanning the
qr code on screen and start playing
today and use promo code antio media for
a huge in-game bonus download call of
antia magic and puzzles will wait my
friends and then when peacemaker arrives
to steal from a racist which by the way
is always okay as long as you ain't
stealing racist people's ideas we the
audience get what is in my opinion the
most exciting peacemaker easter egg that
we have gotten so far by the teaser that
is a potential nod towards the based
grodd himself gorilla grodd the flash's
greatest zoo themed dc nemesis and one
that i have been wanting to see for the
longest time like thank god and this
easter egg happens of course when a news
reporter on augie's tv mentions
authorities struggling to grasp the
mystery of charlie the silverback
gorilla's disappearance chaos at the
evergreen zoo this morning as zookeepers
report
charlie the silverback gorilla is
missing and judging by what this show
seems to be setting up with these
butterflies having been secretly planted
across the world for the longest time it
seems to me that peacemaker could very
well be a secret origin story for jungle
god gorilla grog because i can very much
see a brain crawling butterfly being the
cause for charlie the gorilla becoming a
sentient primate of crime a crime mate
and moving on when peacemaker is
stealing all of his dad's old helmets we
can see one helmet with the name bound
for good underneath and another with the
words x-ray vision in addition to an old
peacemaker shield in the background that
looks like one that his dad used to use
and then immediately after this we
finally get a glimpse at an insanely
comic accurate version of the white
dragon suit that peacemaker's dad used
to wear during his prime supervillain
days as the racist warrior nazi
prisoners love a suit that the astute
vigilante points out has weak points
where the cloth is which i'm sure will
come in very handy for peacemaker when
he inevitably has to fight some type of
racist inside of that suit in the future
because you know what's gonna happen
he's gotta confront his daddy demons
he's probably gonna stab his dad please
stab this man he's a terrible person and
then following this auggie's nosy
neighbor does an amazing piece of dc
canonization when he mentions the mad
hatter one of batman's more forgotten
alice in wonderland to theme villains
while also seeming to forget all those
people batman killed and batman v
superman because apparently this man was
too busy being a nosy ass neighbor to
watch the news batman killed so many
people and man we gotta talk about the
way that adebayo worked vigilante and
shot judo master point blank in the
chest while ignoring her wife's phone
calls like it really does feel like
we're watching the slow rise of a new
amanda waller in the dc eu as leoda gets
more and more hearted to the job it's
almost like we're watching amanda
waller's own rise to power but in a
different form because that marksmanship
is definitely one of leota's gifts that
amanda waller mentioned in an earlier
episode ignore your god-given natural
talent but anyways before vigilante gets
himself arrested on purpose in the most
hilarious way possible you can see an
evergreen police officer holding a
newspaper that further teases the
disappearance of based grodd charlie the
gorilla but also teases a potential plot
to dc's upcoming black adam project with
the headline stating that intergang a
group of prime lord superman villains
who were secretly being fed weapons and
technology from apocalypse by you know
dark sides people has used these weapons
to seize control of black adam's nation
of kondok which is something that i'm
sure dwayne the rock johnson will not be
too pleased about this july not at all
but this very much also confirms that
darkseid is very much coming to the dceu
very soon well again but you know
snattercup didn't necessarily count i
guess and of course we also get a
reference to 1970s disney dingus's the
apple dumpling gang by mern while
chastising his team who seems to have a
really oddly solid knowledge of human
media despite being a freaking insect
from outer space trapped inside a black
man's body run economist you gon die
next i'm just kidding but actually if
project butterfly does indeed have its
roots within the scarabs of the alien
reach race of the dc comics then much
like blue beetle scarab was repurposed
to fight for humanity instead of for the
invasion of humanity maybe mern's
butterfly is doing the same for the dcu
as a good butterfly because much like
starro and the suicide squad there seems
to be a lot more to these aliens than
amanda waller is letting on butterflies
they're not what you think
they are shouldn't have brought judo to
a gunfight [ __ ] but anyways those were
all the major easter eggs and things
that you may have missed in this episode
four of peacemaker my god is this show
amazing i'm so glad that the dceu is
like making really fun and creative
content like this and i'm very much
excited for episode five let us know
what you thought of episode four in the
comment section below but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
please follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] and weird theories but more
importantly please follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and on
youtube and when you do on youtube make
sure you hit that notification bell so
you get notifications every time we
upload a video and also make sure to hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can get
cool shorts like this thank you guys so
much for watching i love you guys so
much and i'll see you guys very soon
goodbye
[Music]
you